this next story is really important and I
want to be sure I'm explaining it clearly
because
it is so important to understand.
So we had a democratic debate last week.
This was the debate number five in the democratic
presidential primary.
It was on MSNBC and you probably noticed that
there were a lot of people who didn't speak
very much.
There were people on the stage who didn't
talk nearly as much as other people.
Now, I've already said we just need fewer
people on the stage.
The requirements to make the debates are too
low and they're allowing a lot of people in
who have absolutely no chance of securing
the nomination.
Voting starts in like, what is it, six weeks
at this point or seven weeks?
Something like that.
We need to be able to hear more from people
who have a shot.
We should have fewer people, but the people
on stage should really split the time evenly
because we notice that not everybody gets
equal time.
In general.
We have a sense that if you're polling better,
you get more time.
And if you're pulling worse, you get less
time.
Uh, and that in some vague way speaking time
is correlated to how you're polling polling
higher.
You get more time pulling, lower, you get
less time.
Now, as I've said before, I get wanting to
hear from the people who have a shot at winning,
but I don't believe the solution is put 10
people up on the stage and mostly talk to
five of them.
The solution is make the requirements such
that there are only five people on the stage
and then everybody gets the same amount of
time.
That's how I think it should be done.
But the data around speaking time and polling
is actually way more interesting than we thought.
Dave C, who's one of our viewers sent me a
graph that he put together, which put on a,
uh, on an X, Y axis Screentime and polling.
And it exposes some very interesting, but
at the same time unsurprising realities, which
are that the network had its favorites and
it was noticeable beyond just how it correlated
with polling.
So let's go through this.
Dave, put this together himself.
The polling data is from real clear politics
on debate day.
The screen time is as measured by CNN.
I'll describe it for people listening, but
this is worth checking out on video as well.
The vertical axis is speaking time, the horizontal
axis is polling average and then you see this
dotted line through the chart, the graph,
which is the amount of speaking time that
we would expect if it corresponded perfectly
to polling.
So what we very quickly notice is that in
a general sense people polling better spoke
more, but there are some very important exceptions.
For example, Bernie Sanders is closest to
the amount of speaking time that would correspond
to his polling.
Sanders is closest to the dotted line.
Elizabeth Warren, on the other hand, got slightly
more speaking time than her polling would
predict.
Joe Biden got slightly less speaking time
that his polling would predict, but the most
interesting thing is that is a cluster of
candidates that got well more than their polling
would dictate and another set that got way
less the candidate who was most screwed.
What I mean is the candidate who speaking
time, uh, fell short of what you would expect
based on their polling by the most is Andrew
Yang.
If you look at how far below the line Andrew
Yang speaking time is from what polling would
predict, Andrew Yang was the most disadvantaged
candidate.
Thanks to the moderation relative to polling.
Then you see Tom Stier and to a lesser degree,
Tulsi Gabard all got less speaking time than
their polling would predict.
But then look above the dotted line where
Amy Klobuchar, Camila Harris and Cory Booker
all got more time than their pulling would
predict.
And then the biggest beneficiary, thanks to
how MSNBC moderated the debate was none other
than Pete Buddha judge based on his polling,
P booted judge is the candidate who speaking
time exceeded what his polling would predict.
So let's now put this into context.
I believe that candidates who qualify should
get roughly equal speaking time.
I believe lots of people on stage shouldn't
be there because they have no shot.
This is already debate number five and voting
starts in like six or seven weeks.
But if you believe that the candidates should
get speaking time based on how they're polling,
that also didn't happen.
Buddha, judge Warren Booker Harris and Clover
char to different degrees got more speaking
time than their polling would predict.
Bernie got roughly the right amount.
Biden got a little less, but yang Stier and
Gabard got much less, particularly Andrew
Yang.
This is how the network moderation continues
to help or hurt candidates.
The solution of course is networks should
commit to giving roughly equal time to each
candidate and there should be fewer candidates
through stricter requirements to making the
debates in the first place.
Pretty clearly the network is pushing establishment
candidates.
When you look at who benefited, it was Booker
Harris club, Machar and Buddha judge the most
and Warren slightly who got more time than
they would based on polling.
No, that Biden got less time, but that sort
of makes sense for two reasons.
One is that his polling is so high that it's
not shocking that his time was slightly underrepresented,
otherwise he would just be talking way, way
too much.
It's also, by the way, probably to Joe's advantage,
not to speak so much as he blunder so often
when he does open his mouth, but the point
here is that even by what I believe is the
wrong way to distribute speaking time, which
is matching, speaking time to polling, MSNBC
greatly failed screwing some people and giving
some others more speaking time than they deserved.
Really nice job by Dave.
See putting this data together.
Let me know what you think.